[Shoshanah speaking in German]
Dearest, this is the third time I'm writing directly to you
without ever having received any acknowledgement.
I can only repeat what I write in all these cards,
that I'm thinking of you with constant longing
and unchanged affection.
And that my heart has a great wish and hope
To be reunited with you one day.
...postcards that I was researching through
the Holocaust Centre in Huddersfield.
They mostly are written by Hugo Friedman,
who was a businessman in Vienna.
And some of them were written by his wife, Hildegard.
And they are to what we think was a-
She was actually a qualified nurse, Irma Doll.
And she lived in Vienna also, but we think she did some
possibly nannying work for Hugo and Hildegard.
Because they had two children.
They eventually got deported.
They all died in the Holocaust.
So, the postcards were sent to Irma Doll from Terezin.
[Shoshanah speaking in German.]
Ich umarme und küsse dich wie eh und je. Dein, Hugo.
The style of writing people have said is quite affectionate
And quite optimistic as well, which is interesting.
It doesn't seem to contain doom and gloom.
Having said that, whilst there's no particular evidence
of Hugo's postcards being censored, each postcard,
from every prisoner were checked, so that there was
no overt messages in there of, you know,
what the conditions were like.
It's interesting to see [inaudible]
the concerns they have for people.
So they're talking very little about themselves
Other than the daily routine and
And quite often inquiring about other people that they knew
in Vienna or that other family members or...
I've always been curious about the typed element of communications
from concentration camps, because there is some interest
in whether there is any coding in there.
And if you look at the postcards, there are quite often
what you'd class as a typewriter errors.
So one letter comes out as bold or
slightly different to the other letters.
And there's two or three examples of that
across different postcards.
Now, not exclusive to Hugo,
but generally across communications
from concentration camps and holding camps.
Whether there is some coded messaging in there
by putting those letters together
and obviously in their language,
seeing if there's any sort of - [inaudible]
It seems credible, that at some point,
somebody would have tried to
communicate certain details through this,
this writing, communication.
Because I can only sort of say from my own psyche,
I think I would definitely try to put, you know,
some sort of message out there that would hint
at what was actually happening,
especially with somewhere, for instance,
like Terezin that was used as a propaganda machine.
And of course, the people in Terezin
would be aware that that was being staged.
But I think the drive to actually, well, counter that
would be too tempting for people who are
going to be able to sit down and actually think:
How can I do this? How can I get-
even if it's just one sentence: out.
Then you know it's got to be worth a try.
[Shoshanah reading German]
Excerpt from the Nazi propaganda film about Theresienstadt.
So the library excerpt begins with a shot outside
And there's a signposting to the library
And then it cuts to someone entering
the glass door of the library.
We see the library desk and the staff there.
There's a lady.
And then there's men conversing, holding books.
It all seems very professional.
We see straight into the library with
many, many stacks of books.
There must be hundreds of them.
It all seems very professional.
And there are men reading books in the library,
conversing over books, we see, what we think,
is Hugo Friedman in a suit and bow tie.
And he sits down at a desk.
Everyone is smartly dressed in suits with jackets.
And also wearing the Star of David badges.
When they arrived at Terezin,
they were allowing us a number of suitcases,
and he'd filled his suitcase with books,
I think much to his wife's delight, you know,
rather than provisions and clothes,
and possibly medicines and things like that.
He'd actually brought books.
The postcards were sent to
number 16 Malzgasse in Vienna.
That is actually a synagogue.
Irma Doll's home address was Bauernmarkt 21.
Rather than sending them to her home address,
Hugo and Hildegard was sending them to a synagogue.
A 16 minute walk from Irma's
Bauernmarkt 21 address.
One of the interesting parts of
compiling an object biography
is looking at the geography almost,
of people involved around objects.
The: is it practical
and sensible that this Irma Doll
that I've located at this address
would have visited these addresses?
So she would have left her house,
but where I believe her house would have stood,
there's some billboards up at the moment
and it looks to have been some development work.
And then she would have turned right
down on to Fleischmarkt.
And then she would have turned
onto Rotenturmstraße
and she would have more or less walked then,
in a straight line across
the river there, which would have brought her
onto the other side,
where she would have continued on to Marienbrücke,
and then she would have turned left on to
Obere Donaustraße.
She would have only walked 220 metres
and then turned right on to Friedrich-Wilhelm -
She would have ended up in Leopoldgasse
which is quite a Jewish area, it was then
and I believe it still is now.
She's heading more towards the direction
of where the Friedman's lived -
The intended location would have been,
at this stage, the synagogue on Malzgasse.
The synagogue was destroyed
as part of the Kristallnacht
But there's also quite near there now,
quite interestingly, there's a
a Sigmund Freud Museum as well
So then she would have got to the Synagogue
There. Now that's where she would have been
collecting the letters from Hugo and his family.
It became a synagogue in 1906.
It was destroyed in 1938.
And then it was used for the infirm and elderly
from 1939 until 1942.
Because that might be Irma's association
with this particular building,
other than the Jewish synagogue.
Because she was a nurse.
In June of 1942, it became one of the four
Jewish assembly points in Vienna,
in preparation for their deportation.
So that whole journey would have taken
about 16 minutes from her home,
across to the synagogue.
She could then continue on to the Friedmann's house,
Obviously, when they were still resident there
before they were deported.
This this journey was particularly interesting to me,
because I wanted to be reassured
that I was looking at the right person.
To me to actually do at this stage
a Street View walk from Irma Doll's home address
to the synagogue, and then a little bit further
to Hugo's house in Vienna is quite fascinating.
Because I'm seeing what they saw,
to some extent I know the landscapes
and buildings have changed.
But not so drastically that you can't be actually stood
on the same pavement or leant against the same wall
or looking at the same windows,
you know, touching the same door.